that was an absolutely sensational piece
you did in ireland
i loved it very thanks remember you've
been back right i went there about 15
years ago to seek out my roots
and uh i found just the little
foundation of a house that they you know
the philbins lived in in the 18th
century i think
really nothing else would they like you
do you think the philbins were they well
you know when we got to this
hi andy how you doing i'm fine
were you getting a haircut before i got
a little trim you're covered
well your girl should have brushed me
off she was a general
or she has a challenge with you i don't
know her name either
now uh so you went there so i went there
so when i found the house uh
then i went to the town where the house
was located right and i invited all the
philbins
you know to attend a little party a
little cocktail party i was having
for all my relatives all me cousins so
i i invited all the philbins i think
there were about 32 people who lived in
this town
and 45 people showed up they all took
advantage of the wealthy american you
know what i mean
i bet all the ones that were related to
you talked like you too i bet it was a
whole village of people going how are
you how you doing
it's good to see you what's going on
he's funny isn't he
that was a mistake richard no no what
what you'll pay no
no you are funny i love i'm not kidding
you i love the piece it was a great
piece
thank you something you should always
say
we do take these yeah 40 years ago john
wayne went to ireland and made the quiet
man
yeah and now in the 90s you go to
ireland and make the
loud man there you go on fire
yeah well i read your book the old
switcheroo
yeah i like what you're talking about
you wrote a book the old switcheroo you
know i want to let people in on a little
secret a little bit
regis was nice enough to have me over to
his house no celebrity invites me to
their house they shouldn't i hope it
never happens again
but you invited you and your wife joy
invited my girlfriend and i over your
house and then re-just gave me the tour
of his whole house and my favorite part
was regis said
you got to see my weight room you got to
see where i work out and he took me down
into the basement and showed me your
weight room and on the walls are giant
pictures of you
everywhere nothing like that
i thought i gotta get a room like that
well it's just with
giant pictures of of not me you but it's
rapping
all these years i've got all these
pictures i don't know what to do with
them where to put them
you know what i mean andy i know what
you mean
i'm all around the weight room i don't
know what else to do with it now you're
you have an obsession with andy richter
and i know why
people don't i don't know if uh if if
younger people know this but there was a
show in the 60s
the joey bishop show and you were the
sidekick that's right i i was andy you
were andy
and we're andy siddik and so we don't
have many talk show sidekicks on the
show
how's andy doing you know get he is the
only one left
he's the only one doing this kind of a
job
and only i know the frustration andy
really feels but has never really voiced
you do you think it's easy to sit here
and watch you be the star of the show
i know what's going inside andy's mind i
know what's going inside your heart
you're sick and tired of it aren't you
andy you want to sit
there don't you say it auntie come on
no not really
look at andy i don't really see a
seething cauldron yeah believe me there
is a cauldron there
absolutely human nature you did a famous
thing you uh you walked off the air at
one point off the joy bishop show
yeah and you said i'm not coming back
till i get the uh the attention that i
deserve
[Laughter]
you were you have gone crazy i'm gonna
tell it my way
money no uh we were off to a to a rather
slow start we were taking on johnny
carson the show it just started and when
it didn't get off to a fast start the
network began getting worried
and maybe it was the announcer's fault
you know so you hear that enough and
then finally maybe
maybe it is so i said goodbye to joey
thank you
or did you resign i walked off i said
you know i uh thanks for the break and
good luck with the show and
and i was gone and i came back of course
i know dummy
but anyway uh were you hanging around in
the hall where'd you really leave
you want me back here i left i left but
have you ever had the desire to just
walk away and leave
uh like how many times each show yeah
he's only matching my desire to leave
half the time oh yeah yeah when you're
out here with like your you know
750th baywatch person you know and
you're
you know what i mean sometimes you just
you've been doing this now five years
and you'll be this is our sixth season
oh my gosh
six years and you're tired of baywatch
no no i like the ladies
they watch good guess because guys with
the wax
chat those guys with the ripples and
everything yeah
not good but you know what i like what
do you like having guests like you
do you really oh that's nice to hear
out in los angeles uh for kabc tv abc
news
uh in the 70s into the 80s yeah
do you have any uh ideas of i mean uh
with the oscar picks for this year
absolutely
what do you think's gonna happen let's
all get together right now okay what do
you want to hear best picture
yeah best picture saving private ryan
don't you agree
uh do i agree that it'll win or do i
agree that don't pull the pace down andy
just say yes or no
oh i'm sorry i was just trying to be
honest yeah
he's hot tonight he's the honest he's
really a funny guy you should give him a
break but anyway i give him a break
no one watching the show thinks i abuse
him it's backstage that i am using
saving private ryan spielberg for
director roberto
benini for best actress
[Music]
and with us paltrow who i think is the
best of all the young actresses for best
actress
those are my pictures those are your
picks all right we don't agree on
everything no
we don't you know but that's that's okay
uh st patrick's day is this a big day
for you
yeah it is it's uh i walked in the
parade when i was a kid growing up here
in new york city at cardinal hayes high
school and uh
so i know that parade is a traditional
new york event you know and it gets
bigger every year it seems i think it's
still going on right now
well we wanted to do something uh
special tonight
and we understood you had a little saint
patrick's day treat for us
there's only one really irish song that
i know but but i need a little help
and again i have to rely on andy all
right because a few years ago or
whenever it was
i saw andy wear this bonnet and i asked
the
wardrobe if andy be a sport now come on
it'll it'll play better if we do it this
way
okay and now wait was he was he wearing
it on the show or do you see him on the
street i mean he was wearing it on the
show
and i want to sing an irish lullaby you
have to tie it daddy and andy's gonna
and he's gonna be my baby all right
and this is gonna put you right to sleep
andy okay okay i'm getting creeped out
right now
it is the weirdest moment when he called
you daddy i got this weird thing
so did i i guess i'm mommy
i guess you are all right baby
okay baby's ready
this is a song that you were singing in
the piece you only hit it as high as i
did
over in killarney many years ago
me mother sang a song to me in tone so
sweet and low
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'd give the world if she would sing
this song to me this day
[Music]
now don't you cry
[Music]
that's an irish
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice
[Applause]
you'll be performing at the uh dover
down slots in dover delaware
this friday and saturday so uh check him
out and of course live with regis and
kathie lee weekdays check local listings
dolly parton is co-hosting on march 25th
and 27th we're gonna have a lot of fun
with dolly thanks so much
you